THE FACTS, YOU ACCORDINGLY DEAL
WITH THAT PERSON.
BUT I APPRECIATE THE FACTS HE
GAVE.
>> BEFORE THE ATTACK, YOU WENT
AND WARNED YOUR SUPERIORS THAT
SOMETHING WAS COMING, SOMETHING
BAD.
ARE YOU ANGRY THOSE CONCERNS
WENT UNANSWERED AND HAVE THERE
BEEN CHANGES TO THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS AND PERSONNEL TO PREVENT
ANYTHING LIKE THAT FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN?
>> THE CONCERNS THAT I HAD, I
SENT THEM TO THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND.
WHERE THEY STOPPED, I'M NOT
EXACTLY SURE.
BUT THE WAY THINGS WERE
ADDRESSED, MAKING SURE CERTAIN
THINGS HAD BEEN MADE BERD.
WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO.
I HOPE THAT THIS IS -- THE
PLANNING, THE LOGISTICS OF
PROTECTING THE CAPITOL IMPROVE
OR HAS IMPROVED, BUT THERE ARE
THINGS THAT HAVE NOT.
I JUST WALKED THIS MORNING FROM
THE SAME ENTRANCE WHERE I ALMOST
LOST MY LIFE AND THEM AS WELL,
AND THE ONLY THING THAT HAS
CHANGED IS THE GLASS AND THE
DOOR.
THE DOOR HAS NOT BEEN REPLACED.
I WISH IT HAD, IT'S BEEN ALMOST
A YEAR NOW.
I THINK A LOT OF OFFICERS, IF
THEY SEE A LOT OF REINFORCEMENT
OF THE BUILDING, THAT WILL GIVE
THEM A LOT OF SENSE OF
PROTECTION THAT THINGS WILL
IMPROVE AND THAT WILL HELP WITH
MORALE, IT WILL HELP WITH
RETAINING OFFICERS AS WELL.
>> OFFICER FANONE, DO YOU AGREE?
WHAT CHANGES STILL NEED TO BE
MADE?
>> I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
CHANGE THAT NEEDS TO BE MADE
SPECIFICALLY INSIDE THE UNITED
STATES CAPITOL POLICE, THEY NEED
TO CHANGE THE LEADERSHIP CULTURE
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT STARTS
AT THE TOP, AT THE EXECUTIVE
LEVEL.
THE FAILURES OF THE U.S. CAPITOL
POLICE'S COMMAND STAFF ON
JANUARY 6th ARE OUTRAGEOUS.
AND THEY STILL HAVE YET TO BE
ADDRESSED.
THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THEIR
COMMAND STAFF THAT DO NOT BELONG
IN A POSITION OF LEADERSHIP.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR OFFICERS' LIVES.
THEY FAILED THEM ON JANUARY 6th
AND IT'S TIME THAT THEY FOUND A
DIFFERENT CAREER PATH.
>> OFFICER HODGES, EVERYONE AT
THE CAPITOL THAT DAY, ESPECIALLY
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS, LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS, WENT
THROUGH EMOTIONAL TRAUMA.
YOU COULDN'T NOT.
YOU'RE BACK AT WORK.
ARE YOU AND YOUR FELLOW
OFFICERS, ARE YOU GETTING THE
SUPPORT YOU NEED, THE EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT YOU NEED, WHETHER
PROFESSIONAL OR JUST
INSTITUTIONALLY?
>> YEAH.
THE METROPOLITAN POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAS PSYCHIATRIC HELP
FOR ANYONE WHO NEEDS IT AND IT'S
FREE OF CHARGE.
SO ANYONE WHO FEELS LIKE THEY
NEED IT IS FREE TO GO AND GET
THE HELP THEY NEED FROM THEM.